[Music]
my home is here in mississippi
i've lived in many other places
new york l.a san francisco chicago
but this place defines me
got him when he was four and a half
months old
undernourished
but he had attitude
got a great walking game
[Music]
it's the smell of grass in the spring
sound of birds
i just know i'm home
my parents live right here on this land
you can't understand me
without understanding where i was
created
every religion has a creation story
so
what did those stories tell us about who
we are and where we came from
i'm setting out to discover
where we begin
jerusalem is conceived of as eden as
paradise
to unearth civilization's oldest roots
this is the mayan life that's the
myogenesis story
to locate the genesis of religion itself
people are literally living with
ancestors
and i'll go back
to the dawn of time hindus do not
believe in one creation
they say that these are cycles of
creation
to discover if science and religion
can coexist
the big man is not creation because we
don't know what was before the big bang
[Music]
there are billions of us on this planet
it's hard to believe we all came from
one man and one woman
but we did
[Music]
who were
they when and where did they live
jewish christian and muslim traditions
trace us all back to adam and eve
the book of genesis says they came from
a place called eden
near the tigers and euphrates rivers
somewhere in the ancient near east
no one has yet found the location of the
garden of eden though many have tried
but
why do we want to find it
well the reason is interesting
the garden of eden doesn't just
represent the beginning of humanity
it is the beginning of our conversation
with god
and finding out when and where that took
place
would tell us an awful lot about who we
are
so
i'm off to jerusalem
this is one of the oldest cities in the
world
there's evidence of people living around
here for more than seven thousand years
today is the religious center of the
jewish world
it was here that genesis was first
written down
about 2500 years ago
archaeologist jody magnus is taking me
to the church of the holy sepulcher
where there is a little known link to
the garden of eden
so this is it
this is the church of the holy sepulchre
many christians believe this is the site
where jesus was crucified and buried
but another ancient tradition says
there's also the burial place
had them
the area that we're walking into here is
underneath the rock of golgotha which is
the rocky outcrop on which christians
believe jesus was crucified
and this is called the chapel of adam
there's a tradition which goes way back
in christianity which connects this spot
to adam the first man
when jesus was crucified on top of the
rock above us
his blood
flowed down through a crack in the rock
and adam the first man lay buried
underneath and when jesus's blood flowed
onto adam adam was then resurrected
almost 1700 years ago when roman emperor
constantine built the church
he also made a shrine around this crack
in the rock of golgotha
the chapel of adam
but doesn't this contradict that section
of the bible that says that the garden
of eden was located somewhere near the
euphrates and the tigris cycles well the
version of the story that ended up in
the book of genesis
seems to place the garden of eden
somewhere in
mesopotamia which is the area of modern
iraq
how do you think the tradition
of adam gets to be here in jerusalem
well i think adam probably does have a
very special connection with jerusalem
the garden of eden or paradise
becomes conceptualized as a spot where
the presence of god dwells in early
judaism in the time of jesus the
presence of god dwelled in the temple on
the temple mount and hence jerusalem was
conceived of as eden as paradise so
you're saying eden could also be a
metaphor right well yes of course adam
was the first human and in hebrew the
word adam adam just means man
hold up hold up you just said something
now
they're word just means
man yes adam yes
also the name adam if you take off the a
and you just leave d-a-m in hebrew dom
that means blood or if you add an a-h to
the end adamah
means
land and itself into blood yup okay all
right
could the story of adam and eve's
explosion from the garden also have
metaphorical meanings
adam and eve lived in a land of plenty
but when they ate the fruit of the
forbidden
tree they were cast out and forced to
work the land
in other words they became the first
farmers
i'm heading to a region where
researchers are digging up some of
humanity's oldest farming communities
in central turkey
[Music]
i'm interested in finding out if the
birth of farming and the birth of belief
in god are connected
could this have been eaten
[Music]
amy
hello
come on over
archaeologist amy bogard has been
digging with a team here at chattahooia
for two decades
welcome thank you
so
shuttle
9 000 year old settlement
9
000
years old amazing isn't it
so at its maximum extent it's 13
hectares
that would be like 20 football pitches
in extent
right nfl football pitches or
soccer pitches i don't know
probably soccer uh but but they were all
they're all pretty much the same yeah
you can see that these houses are
densely crowded together
there isn't much space between them
there's no space between them yeah they
had no windows or doors
every house would have its own entrance
from above yes
chateau huyoke was a city with no
streets
the people who lived here walked across
town over the rooftops
roofs were also where they worked
the people of chattahook were some of
the world's first city dwellers
but i want to know whether they were
also some of the first believers
did they think their world was created
by a god
amy takes me to a house that may hold
the answers
what's the point of that
red rimmed
hole that looks like very
definite has a definite reason
it's a typical sort of feature that's
found at chateau which is a niche for
hiding things away like they cache
obsidian you know volcanic glass because
it's a valued you know cutting material
don't find it everywhere right
the most important hiding places
archaeologists have found that chateau
huyok
are beneath the sleeping areas
okay so what are those holes over there
those are actually burial places those
are burial pits
wait a minute wait a minute
a human being is not going to fit in
there a baby maybe
the way they can fit mature adults in
pits like that is to bind them up very
very very tightly in a flex position and
the holes are periodically reopened and
new
individuals added through the lifetime
of the house
wow
people are buried under the platforms so
that people are literally living with
ancestors
it sounds like this has some religious
content
i i think you're right
and they start to raise questions about
what you might call ritual practice
which seemed to have been crucial
for life in this community
could these burials be evidence of
belief in god
anthropologist harvey whitehouse is
trying to get inside the heads of these
early city dwellers
so this is a
pretty authentic mock-up of what a
typical kind of house in chateau it
would have looked like these are the
kinds of objects that we'd expect to
find in one of those houses
over here we've got examples of wall art
you know here we've got bull heads we
often find
these inserted into the walls in one
case i've seen them arranged almost like
a sort of protective shield around one
of these clean spaces
and we know that these clean spaces were
used for sleeping on
so harvard you're an anthropologist
so
you're more into what people are
mentally into right
well my
imagination runs right in an environment
like this because i've seen the kind of
stuff that comes out of the walls and
that they've been taking out of the
floors
we know that there were very interesting
rituals surrounding
the burial of human remains but those
objects
would be periodically in many cases
brought out what they were doing with
them we don't really know but in many
cases they were put back very carefully
and replaced
it's almost as if
this isn't just a domestic dwelling this
is like a kind of living temple
who used that word
temple well what is a temple
you know if not a sort of uh an
environment in which uh the ritual life
of a community is conducted and and i
think that's what is going on in these
houses
here in chattanooga they were
obviously
all kinds of
rituals
particularly
burial rituals
but
no sign of an organized religion so the
question remains unanswered for me
did
religion
allow man to
live together
grow food
or
did civilization give rise to our belief
in god
while in chattahooch
i heard about another excavation just a
few hundred miles to the east that may
hold the answer for me it's an 11 000
year old site that lies between the
tigers and euphrates rivers
the biblical location of eden
okay we're now in enclosure d
um the best preserved of the enclosures
that we have here so we've had radio
carbon data and they've come back as
9400 plus minus
bc
it's called gobekli tepe
and here i may find evidence of the very
first moments humans worshiped the
divine
stone age architects built 20 monumental
circuits here made from large t-shaped
pillars
archaeologist lee claire leaves the team
trying to decipher his mysteries
the two central pillars stand in the
middle of a round oval building and the
wall surrounding it at regular intervals
we see smaller t-pillars
fearsome animals were carved into some
of the pillars
but the stones t-shapes may represent
the human form
they could be men
or
they could be gods if you look closely
you have the top the t is that there's a
head
and then we have on the side the broad
side the arm coming down you can see a
belt buckle here they could be
mythological ancestors alternatively
they could be really the first
deities first gods that these people
were possibly worshipping in this in
this circular structure
lee and most archaeologists believe
these stone circles were used for
rituals but no one appears to have
actually lived here
the people of gobekli taffy were roaming
hunter-gatherers
not settled farmers so
why did they build a permanent place of
worship tied to one spot
it's one of the main questions we ask
ourselves at this site so why did they
come now the thing is at this time the
communities were growing larger and
larger there was more stress on the
local
resources and because communities were
growing there was obviously a risk of
conflict
people have problems keeping track of
relationships keeping track of networks
the growing population meant that people
who scarcely knew each other had to work
together that was the recipe for
conflict
the religious rituals that go back to
tepe may have eased those conflicts
for the first time in human history
people from different groups came
together around sharing beliefs
and in those first formative moments of
religion
they may have shared stories about where
they all came from
stories that celebrated a shared past
and drove them together
to the future
go back to taffy traces the birth of
religious worship back more than 11 000
years
long before there were
muslims christians jews hindus buddhists
people came together
to talk
eat
worship
it could be that the driving force
behind our greatest achievement
civilization
was god
but today
we no longer share one story of creation
we live in a global society made up of
many different cultures
and science has given us a new
perspective on creation
it even claims to know the ultimate
secret of our cosmic origins
can science and religion agree on
creation
the story of our creation has puzzled me
ever since i was a boy
it began right here
in a church
in greenwood mississippi
[Music]
so
[Music]
i was about their age when it happened
i remember the minister reading from the
book of genesis there are eight hundred
and seven thousand three hundred and
sixty one words in the bible
it doesn't take eight hundred
seven thousand words for you to believe
the bible
it only takes
ten words
in
the beginning
[Music]
god
created
are y'all gonna get away man
the heavens and the earth
but for me this beginning was a profound
puzzle
one moment there was nothing
the next everything you're looking good
if god created the universe
who was around to create god
when i got older i heard scientists had
found evidence of the big bang
according to that theory
the entire universe burst out of a
single point in an instant of fiery
creation
now that science knows so much about our
cosmic origins
what place is there for religious belief
in the beginning
i want to know about the islamic story
of creation
so i'm going to cairo
[Music]
one of the largest and oldest cities in
the muslim world
islam has deep roots in science
muslim astronomers were charting the
heavens soon after the time of muhammad
i haven't noticed that what is it this
is the minority of al hussein mosque
harvard historian of islam ahmed raghav
is taking me to one of cairo's spiritual
centers
the al hussein mosque
[Music]
and
the lines are all closed you don't you
shouldn't have any kind of uh space
between yeah
in other words it just kind of told to
toe
[Music]
muslims come here every day
to give thanks to god for all that he
creates
[Music]
and afterwards some had just around the
corner to the two and a half century old
el tishawi coffee shop
speak to me about the
the islamic concept
of creation in islam the beginning of
the story starts with this massive cloud
of smoke
from which the heaven and earth are
pulled
from inside the smoke and then the earth
after that gets formed into what it
looks like
uh before the beings are created
interestingly that is very
cosmic
right
you think right away about the clouds of
dust in the cosmos that form worlds
so this ideas about these massive clouds
and things coming out of them is
actually very powerful in a lot of
mythological traditions around the world
and it is part of this islamic narrative
of creation
in islam
the moment of creation exists alongside
the scientific view of earth's formation
the same is true for traditions much
older than islam
aboriginal people have lived in central
australia for tens of thousands of years
they've told the story of this land's
creation for as long as anyone can
remember
oh this is beautiful
my grandfather's family have been
caretakers for his place
you know it's coming past time to be
warren williams
and the orende people call this place
home
this place is so big you'd have to see
it from space you could probably see it
on satellite i mean
cultural astronomer dwayne hammacker
tries to connect aboriginal creation
stories to modern science
so warren is taking him to where his
ancestors say it all began
a bowl-shaped basin
called
noralan
it's traditional for the arunde to tell
their creation story at night
when they can see their creators the sky
guards
these guys
they're gonna be really good tonight
they're all coming out now
the story takes place in an era called
the dreaming
when the sky gods lived in the milky way
the dreaming is a period of creation
when everything was
beginning and the ladies were dancing
at a ceremony and one of them had a
little baby
so she put the baby in a toner like a
it's a wooden cradle but all the dancing
started vibrating shaking the milky way
and the turnip fell down
and it fell to earth and created
the crater that we see now
that's fascinating because according to
scientists it was an asteroid or a comet
that hit the ground
and what it did is you know the massive
explosion created this big meteorite
crater
dwayne wants to know more about the
turner or cradle that warren and his
ancestors see
as the cause of their creation
so you can see the milky way quite
clearly and that looks like that
tournament from the front falling out of
the milky way in western astronomy we
call that corona astralis that
constellation means the southern crown
but you're right it looks exactly like
turnip falling out the milky way it
looks like an upturned cradle
at daybreak dwayne asked warren to show
him exactly where the star baby landed
goes right through here
check it out it's right in the center of
the meteor impact crater geologists
called goss's club
so this is it
this is where it began
when the rocks fell down here to the
ground
and um performed this
then the first man could create the
first woman got created
and now i'm here
because of that
it started here just
fell from this guy had made made all
this
science has never really considered some
of these old creation stories to have
any validity what we're finding out is
that the creation story from the
aboriginal perspective and from the
scientific perspective like here at nora
are identical they're exactly the same
for the arende
life began here
and tradition requires a greeting to the
ancestors whenever you enter this sacred
space
[Music]
science can live side by side with
aboriginal and islamic accounts of our
origins
now i'm curious about science and the
judeo-christian creation story
so i've come to rome
michelangelo's breathtaking sistine
chapel ceiling depicts the book of
genesis
in six days god creates light
makes the sun and the
moon and creates man
[Music]
i've come to speak with the pope's chief
science representative monsignor marcelo
sanchez sorondo
now you are the chancellor of the
pontifical academy of sciences exactly
when did that get started and why
in 1603
1603 and three years
and the leader of the first generation
was galileo
and the idea is to have
a new
academy
to develop the scientific reason of
things
so we have the two different approaches
to the idea
of creation levels of genesis
and then there's the big bang
the big bang is not creation exactly
because
we don't know we don't know
what was before the big bang
my question exactly
and for this reason creation is nothing
to do
with
the big man
the other thing is that
the idea of the bible
is not a scientific idea of creation in
other words science can't prove it or
disprove it exactly we say in the bible
is the idea of creation but
in the theological sense of creation not
the scientific sense of creation thank
you thank you
the catholic church no longer sees the
book of genesis as the literal
description of creation
in fact the first scientist to propose
the big bang george lemaitre was a
priest and a member of the pontifical
academy of science
so how exactly does belief in god
fit into modern cosmology
so this incredibly high water ceiling
just like reaching for heaven
yes
in a certain sense
it's a representation of a heaven
of a theological heaven
i'm meeting with father giuseppe
tanzeliniti
a scientist at the vatican observatory
i'm very very fascinated by
you you're an astronomer
and you are a holy man yes my field of
study was
radiographics
quasars extra galactic objects
and it was another kind of hammond i
remember that
when we take a galaxy spectra
i used to pray
during the waiting for the spectra
and to say god i thank you for this
marvelous universe that you gave us
there must have come at some point
a question for you
about the nature of
creation
we think that there's like a big schism
between the biblical sense of
creation and the other one is the
scientific sense of the big bang and
it's all very different creation from a
theological point of view is
perfectly compatible
with a big bank
because you need
always a first cause god the creator is
outside space time
it's before any time so the act of
creation
is an everlasting act because creation
is the way in which god continuously
holds the universe
for giuseppe and others like him
cosmology not only allows room for
divine creation
it offers new ways to understand god
as the master of space and time
i like what father giuseppe says about
creation as a continuum
that it
didn't begin
and end with the big bang
it is
god's ongoing activity which includes
evolution
i think what he was saying is god does
not exist outside space and time
god is space and time
the idea that creation is ongoing sounds
like a new one
but it's not
in the depths of the guatemalan
rainforest
lost cities reveal the endless creations
of the ancient maya
[Music]
what if there was not one moment of
creation
but many
i'm headed out to explore the remains of
the ancient mayan empire
where a new discovery sheds light on
their genesis story
[Music]
few roads cut through the dense jungle
of northern guatemala today
but archaeologist richard hanson tells
me that 2000 years ago
this was one of the great cities of the
and new york is world a modern city but
these guys have the same perspective of
their own cities right
that water delivery system to have
freeways oh yeah
[Music]
this pyramid is one of the largest
structures in the world in terms of
volume
it's uh more than a half a mile long at
the base
at a site called el mirador richard
found the remains of an ancient city the
maya knew as the snake kingdom
it's such a rich archaeological site he
set up a permanent camp in the jungle to
explore it
this is the laboratory this is our
doctor if you're ever getting a problem
he can fix you right there
outstanding
[Laughter]
nice to meet you yeah it was nice to
meet you wasn't it what it's very
let's do it
richard is taking me to see something
he's only just uncovered
okay this is
one of the most interesting excavations
we have right now oh my goodness
this is art that was carved in stucco
hundreds of years before christ
and it has incredible scenes showing the
entire pantheon of the minor religion
so what we're talking about is this is
the actual story of creation here
this is the mayan bible this the myogen
is the story with all the deities that
are needed to tell the story yeah this
is this is unbelievable
i mean if you just think about the fact
that
it wasn't done in the 15th century of
the 16th century
it was done 2000 years ago at least
this is the oldest version of the maya's
sacred story of creation that's ever
been found
the focus is on two swimmers carrying a
severed head
it's this head right here that gave us
the clue who this might be at the first
place
we think this is hunapu this is the
father of the hero twins that starts the
whole process of creation
of this creative story survive even to
this day in a religious ritual
in which i am privileged to take part
the ritual recalls the saga of the corn
god being tricked into going down to the
underworld where he's decapitated
his sons known as the hero twins set off
to rescue him
but they can only get to the underworld
by being burned to ash
the ash ever since the hero tweets
she mixed the corn with the ashes and
that goes into the water
as their ash sinks into the subterranean
waters
the hero twins regenerate
they return to earth with the corn god's
head
and plant him in the ground
it is from this corn
that the first maya people are made
now the hero friends are in the river
so listen to what they're gonna be
serving
and passing around
in a sense we all become a part of the
hero twin story by doing this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we don't perform rituals to celebrate
adam and eve
but the hero twins were crucial to mayan
culture
their story of death and rebirth was
tied to the growth of their staple crop
corn
an act of creation that the maya
depended on every year
[Music]
and richard tells me
their architecture also focused on
creation
it mirrored the source of power they saw
in the heavens
to show me how
he takes me 40 miles away to the ruins
of the city of cacao
[Music]
the temples here are arranged in groups
of three
a triad
so richard
now i can sense here that there is a
pattern but
something's missing what am i missing
well there is a pattern morgan this is a
definite pattern here and it's
consistent through centuries of time
there's one big building over here with
the stairway facing inward
another building over here with the
stairway facing one okay and that third
one
the third one was right in front of us
oh there's the third structure it's been
dismantled of course it's gone now but
the big the big building was right in
front of us it was
as high or higher
which was built to make the triad three
stones
richard and other experts believe this
arrangement of stone temples is a
deliberate echo of a triangle of stars
in the constellation orion at the center
of the three stars is a fiery nebula a
cosmic cloud of star creation you know
from contemporary maya that there is a
celestial heart the end star of orion
it's in the constellation of orion
even today when the maya light a
traditional fire they begin by planting
three stones a fire of creation emanates
from their center
just as it does with the triad of stars
in orion
you're telling me that the lions
got this triad
this manifestation of creation
from the constellation
orion it looks like this is what they
were looking at we know that they were
very aware of three primary stars so the
maya were able to replicate that pattern
with these three stones in these three
structures and that is replicated over
and over and over again they're tying us
to the heavens
they're letting us see the creation
symbolically
[Music]
looking around here
i'm struck by the scale of what the maya
created
huge cities
colossal pyramids
it was a civilization whose religion
was focused on creation
and the continued regeneration of
creation and yet
it all crumbled
everything the maya created
collapsed
it strikes me that we don't spend enough
time celebrating the paths our ancestors
tried to get here
all giving thanks for the forces that
sustain our lives
but there is one culture that gives
thanks for its creation every day
and i'm in varanasi india
to see it
[Music]
india is home to a billion hindus
the third largest faith in the world
it has many gods and many creation
stories
one of the best known
centers around the river that gives them
life the ganges
or
ganga morgan now we are at
the river ganga manga ganga the holiest
of the holy rivers and the center of
hindu universe it only exists because it
is the sacred the pure the holy from the
heavens it only exists because you
believe you believe yes
okay
historian bender parang japan takes me
to a shrine
to ganga
careful yes
ganga is not only a river
but a goddess
so the idea is that you bow down even
before you enter the shrine
but not for a short person like me
and then you come to a place where you
see mother ganga
what's she holding in her upper left
hand
she's holding a lotus that is supposed
to be a
mark of purity right because lotus
emerges out of mud but it does not take
any stains of mud
in the beginning
hindus believed ganga flowed in the
heavens
but she was held captive by the creator
god brahma
then brahma decided to send the river
ganga down to earth
but there is one problem that ganga has
got such mighty force and if she comes
on the earth the earth will drown
so the god shiva
blocked ganga's fall
gathering her waters in the locks of his
hair
so she would just open one lock of his
hair and the ganga flew
[Music]
she is the mother because she gives
birth to everything
this holy river came from
the
river in heaven that we call the milky
way they say that milky way actually is
a reflection that you see in those
waters which are still beyond
sciences have dated the universe
to about 14 billion years
best we can figure
hindus have it at what
hindus do not believe in one creation
they say that these are cycles of
creation okay and the primordial
creation could be something like 8.6
billion years ago actually this whole
creation myth is very difficult to
comprehend because we say the gods like
brahma has created the universe but then
they ask a question who created brahma
right and then always to question them
creation happened and then the gods
happened
they say that the sages when they were
in their trance
they got that revelation that how the
creation
happened
but
since it is in that level of
consciousness
you and me we commoners will not
understand it so we believe that it's
beyond us
the hindu philosophy is not to try to
solve the riddle of creation that
happened long ago
it's to give thanks every day for the
forces that allow us to be here and
continue to sustain us
including the river ganges
you can come looking close
we are going to see the ritual which
they call it
yeah it means showing the lamp to the
god
the rt has taken place on the banks of
the holy river every night for hundreds
of years
the prayer is that
god
you are like my father you are like my
mother my whole existence is you
my whole existence is you i'm just like
a shadow i'm a vessel
that contains
that's wonderful
seven priests offer all the elements to
gander
water
air earth in the form of flowers
and the most important of all
light
which represents our souls
[Music]
as the ceremony closes
people gather at the water's edge to
place the light of their own souls in a
tiny vessel
this is our individual way of offering
ourselves to the river
and the
candy that takes our soul to the river
it's the light of my soul my soul and it
says that you take it wherever you think
is good for me
[Music]
the hindu version of creation appeals to
me
it says the guards weren't even around
at the original creation
they have this great saying from the rig
veda
[Music]
about the beginning
there was neither
non-existence
nor existence
it's saying the idea is beyond human
definition beyond
human intellect
just
accept it
[Music]
where did we come from
a man and a woman banished from paradise
to begin to work the land
hero twins planting the corn they need
to start a civilization
a great river that gives life to an
entire people
these ideas about where we came from are
the oldest stories we have
they are shared words and distant
memories that form the glue of our
civilization
we don't all share the same creation
story
we all come from different places
but all of us
whatever we believe
can share in one thing
the wonder and gratitude
that we are here at all
[Music]
it is my fervent hope
that people will open their hearts and
minds
and see that
our beliefs don't have to
divide us
they have the power
to unite us
to allow us together to achieve
remarkable things
as it was in the beginning
is now
and ever shall be
world without end
[Music]
you